le président l'a public nous tient des
discours de fermeté sur l'immigration
alors depuis quelques semaines et là il
profite de son voyage à mayotte pour
tenir ce discours mais le problème c'est
qu'il a un bilan qui fait qu'il n'est
absolument pas crédible quand il parle
d'immigration
quand on regarde les chiffres le nombre
de titres de séjours délivrés en 2010 8
bat des records le nombre de
régularisation des immigrés illégaux en
2018 a augmenté de 7% par rapport à
l'année précédente et la france est
devenue la championne d'europe en
matière de droit d'asile
tous les temps les voyants sont au rouge
et le bilan monsieur maquereau en
matière de lutte contre les les flux
migratoires ce bilan il est très mauvais
donc monsieur macron neymar sur les mâts
crédible aujourd'hui quand il nous parle
d'immigration la loisy l'immigration
qu'on a voté à l'assemblée nationale
doute pas fait grand cas et grands frais
nous on avait dénoncé les points de
faiblesse et le fait qu'elle
encouragerait même l'immigration par
exemple matière de regroupement familial
cette loi elle a montré qu'elle était
totalement inefficace donc au delà des
discours de l'argent qu'il faut
évidemment investir à mayotte des
mesures qu'il faut prendre
nous on attend du président de la
république des actes de vrais actes